[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
die sportlichen überraschungen in
münchen präsentiert nachher norbert
lehmann
wir haben unter anderem diese themen für
sie
keine mehrwertsteuer auf die gasanlage
darum hat finanzminister lindner die eu
gebeten sagt er im zdf sommerinterview
woran sterben die fische in der oder
deutschland fordert aufklärung von polen
und zwei mal gold beim turnen elisabeth
seitz ist europameisterin am
stufenbarren emma malewski gewinnt am
schwebebalken
ab oktober kommt auf privathaushalte und
betriebe die gas verbrauchen eine neue
belastung zu die gasanlage ihre höhe
will die regierung morgen bekanntgeben
eigentlich müsste darauf auch noch
mehrwertsteuer gezahlt werden doch das
zumindest versucht der finanzminister
mit einem brief an die eu abzuwenden
christiane hübsche hat mehr
32 grad im regierungsviertel
sommerinterview mit christian lindner
morgen kommt mit der verkündung der
gasanlage eine neue zumutung für viele
bürger das darauf aber auch noch
mehrwertsteuer gezahlt wird soll nach
dem willen des finanzministers nicht
passieren habe nach brüssel geschrieben
und setze mich dafür ein dass abzuwenden
nehmen sie für heute einfach am tag
bevor die umlage kommt den politischen
willen der bundesregierung dass wir
nicht von der mehrwertsteuer profitieren
wollen ansonsten bekräftigt lindner
gegenüber dem zdf was er alles nicht
will keine fortsetzung des neuen euro
tickets keine über gewinn steuer für
energiekonzerne die an der krise
verdienen wir würden unser steuersystem
der willkür ausliefern alle die sich
damit in meinem ministerium beschäftigen
warnen davor und deshalb sage ich in
deutschland sind gewinne bereits sehr
hoch besteuert da kommt er erneut
widerspruch vom grünen
wirtschaftsminister da ist geld und zwar
geld mit dem die konzerne oder betreiber
von energieanlagen selbst nicht
gerechnet haben da sollte doch einen
teil dazu dienen können verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher zu entlasten
ein beleg dafür wie unterschiedlich die
regierungsparteien in der krise ticken
lindner gesteht ein die fdp leidet immer
wieder forderungen von spd und grünen
den koalitionsvertrag neu zu verhandeln
und die linie der politik weiter nach
links zu verschieben das ist für die fdp
und unsere unterstützerinnen und
unterstützer der große herausforderung
und deshalb haben wir sicherlich einige
wählerinnen und wähler der
bundestagswahl die momentan mit einem
kritischen auge auf uns schauen in den
umfragen liegen die liberalen bei nur
noch sieben prozent
die fdp sei aus staatspolitischer
verantwortung in die ampel eingetreten
so lindner aber sie bewirke gutes
das ganze zdf sommerinterview mit
christian lindner sehen sie direkt nach
uns oder jederzeit in der zdf- heute-
app zwei meldungen zur energieversorgung
obwohl russland seit wochen weniger gas
liefert sind die deutschen speicher
jetzt schon zu mehr als 75 prozent
gefüllt zwei wochen früher als
vorgeschrieben und weil die niedrigen
pegelstände in den flüssen die energie
transporte gefährden will die
bundesregierung ihnen auf der schiene
vorrang geben damit kohle kraftwerke und
raffinerien
ausreichend versorgt werden können zum
massiven fischsterben an der oder da
bemüht sich im moment
bundesumweltministerin lembke in polen
um aufklärung dort sind giftstoffe wohl
schon im juli in die oder gelangt auf
deutscher seite wurde tonnenweise tote
fische aus dem wasser geholt offen ist
ob auch die oder mündung am stettiner
haff betroffen ist katrin lindner
berichtet der gestank an der oder wird
immer schlimmer seit drei tagen sammeln
angler und fischer bei brieskow
finkenheerd südlich von frankfurt oder
kadaver ein
traurig einfach nur traurig die
ersichtlichen verluste die werden
momentan haben sind erstmal die leicht
fische wir sind die großen fische zander
karpfen
gras karpfen hechte im
polnischen stettin beraten heute abend
die deutsche und die polnische
umweltministerin
wir werden die analyseergebnisse in den
nächsten tagen zusammen führen und eine
übergreifende expertengruppe zusammen
nehmen damit jetzt zusammen gearbeitet
wird um möglichst zeitnah tatsächlich
die erkenntnisse zu gelangen wer ist der
verursacher wer hat dieses verbrechen
begangen und wie kann er zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden morgen
werden in brandenburg laborergebnisse
erwartet geprüft wird ob ein erhöhter
salzgehalt mit dem fischsterben in
zusammenhang steht die untersuchungen in
polen haben bisher ergeben dass
quecksilber und andere schwermetalle
nicht ursache sind
mecklenburg-vorpommern auf der deutschen
seite vom stettiner haff wurden bisher
keine toten fische gefunden
doch es gelten vorsichtsmaßnahmen kein
wasser entnehmen nicht angeln fischen
oder baden dass man dort natürlich die
qualität wenn man bloß aufs wasser
gucken kann von einer entwarnung alle
warten auf antworten was hat das
fischsterben verursacht und wie geht es
weiter
es ist ein trauriger höchstwert in
europa haben feuer in diesem jahr
bereits rund
660.000 hektar wald verbrannt eine
fläche etwa zweieinhalb mal so groß wie
das saarland am stärksten betroffen ist
bisher spanien mit
225.000 hektar experten bezeichnen die
situation europaweit als beunruhigend
man befinde sich erst in der mitte der
brand saison
in ägypten sterben bei einem brand in
einer koptischen kirche nahe kairo
mindestens 41 menschen das feuer brach
während eines gottesdienstes aus unter
den gläubigen kam es zu einer
massenpanik ersten ermittlungen zufolge
könnte ein kurzschluss eine klimaanlage
den brand ausgelöst haben
vor fast genau einem jahr gingen diese
bilder um die welt
chaos am flughafen in kabul verzweifelt
versuchen menschen aus afghanistan zu
fliehen nachdem die radikal islamischen
taliban die hauptstadt und den
präsidenten lasst erobert haben zuvor
hatten bundeswehr und nato ihre truppen
nach 20 jahren aus dem land abgezogen
über die lage jetzt berichten sebastian
ehm und katrin eigendorf
es sind die ärmsten der armen die in den
höhlen von barrieren leben die sich kein
haus leisten können seit der
machtübernahme der taliban gibt es noch
weniger arbeit als zuvor
mein mann geht früh aus dem haus und
arbeitet den ganzen tag auf dem basar
und und dann nur fünf brote nach hause
das reicht nicht für zehn kinder
so viele hoffnungen haben sich
zerschlagen dass sich die spektakulär
schöne region eines tages zu einem
touristen ziel entwickeln könnte und
dass ihre kinder es einmal besser haben
würden doch seit dem mädchen nur noch
bis zur sechsten klasse die schule
besuchen dürfen bis den töchtern der weg
zu einer ausbildung versperrt alle
annahmen und erwartungen dass die
taliban möglicherweise zu reformen
bereit sein könnten haben sich als
wunschdenken erwiesen afghanistan ist
heute ein scharia staat in dem weder
frauen noch menschenrechte gültigkeit
haben auch in kabul wächst die not
menschen drängen sich vor der
lebensmittelausgabe des world food
programms öl mehl und lebensmittel für
säuglinge werden verteilt
die menschen sorgen sich um ihre kinder
viele leiden unter unterernährung die
väter und mütter haben nicht mehr genug
um sie zu füttern
die taliban geben sich zuversichtlich
die krise ihres landes lösen zu können
die führung des islamischen staates tut
ihr bestes um die momentane aktuelle
krise zu lösen wir werden unser land von
den wurzeln an neu aufbauen bislang gibt
es dafür kaum anzeichen ein jahr nach
ihrer machtübernahme können die taliban
nur einen fortschritt für sich
beanspruchen afghanistan ist sicherer
geworden
hat der schnitt jetzt zum sport norbert
doppeltes gold für die deutschen
turnerinnen bei den european
championship das ist wirklich eine
sensation muss man sagen die deutsche
rekordmeister in elisabeth seitz die
gewinn zum abschluss der frauen
wettbewerbe überraschend am stufenbarren
und noch überraschender immer maletzki
die wird europameisterin am
schwebebalken mit
[Musik]
gerade einmal 18 jahren zwei medaillen
in münchen immer malewski wird zum
gesicht der deutschen ton zukunft nach
bronze in der mannschaft bewies die
chemnitzerin auch am schwebebalken ihre
nervenstärke und holte sich die em krone
ich habe keine worte dafür was heute
passiert ist ich freue mich so mega und
mit dieser stimmung das war einfach toll
auch die stimmung bei elisabeth seitz
großartig nach ihrem triumph am
stufenbarren obwohl es keine perfekte
vorstellung der deutschen rekordmeister
in war reichte es für die 28 jährige an
ihrem lieblingsgerät zum ersten
internationalen titel
ja und großer erfolg auch für
deutschlands beste kletterin hanna neue
silber im bouldern an der kletterwand
auf dem münchner königsplatz einem
wahren publikumsmagneten bei diesen
european championships
panama erfüllt sich ihren großen traum
eine medaille bei der heim em zwei mal
kletterte sie in den vier final routen
bis zum top dem höchsten griff an der
viereinhalb meter hohen wand geschlagen
wird sie in einem spektakulären
wettkampf nur von der slowenischen
top-favoritin ja nie agan brett die
21-jährige allrounderin neue gewinnt
damit die erste medaille für den
deutschen alpenverein eine
bronzemedaille gab es heute im paradies
für den mixed vierer und ebenfalls
bronze gewann alexandra küste aus
meschede im ruder einer hinter der
niederländerin caroline flohr 1 und f
angelia anastasia du aus griechenland
irgendwie uns die einzige deutsche
medaille in einer olympischen
bootsklasse also insgesamt eine schwache
wm bilanz für den deutschen ruder
verband jaaa und european championships
am morgen bei uns live zu sehen und zdf
59 geht's los dankeschön noch das wetter
wird wechselhaft und massa morgen ist es
bewölkt dabei vor allem im norden osten
sowie im südwesten einige teils kräftige
schauer und gewitter höchstwerte 24 bis
31 grad ab mitte der woche dann häufiger
regen viertel vor zehn das heute journal
mit marietta slomka wir wünschen ihnen
einen guten start in die neue woche bis
morgen wenn sie mögen hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit dem zdf sommerinterview